hey guys it's August nineteenth I'm Mary
and it's Friday which means we're
counting down the top five biggest
stories in gaming of the week first up
is the xbox one s so hot right now
according to Microsoft it's seeing
unprecedented demand demand has been off
the charts from Microsoft's newly
launched Xbox one s console they haven't
shared any specific sales numbers but
the system's two terabyte version is
sold out in many stores in Europe
thankfully for anyone looking for an
xbox one s more are coming on 23rd there
will be three new versions offered a one
terabyte model that comes with madden
NFL 17 that's 350 bucks there's also a
500 gig version that's 300 bucks and a
one terabyte version that's 350 that
come with halo 5 guardians and halos of
Master Chief collection the Xbox one
makes using an external hard drive easy
so compensating for the smaller hard
drive sizes is painless and relatively
inexpensive the Xbox one s debuted
earlier this month introducing 4k and
HDR support in a smaller sleeker box it
also provides a performance boost in
some but not all games we reviewed the
Xbox one s and you can check that out on
gamespot some sad news this week for
Final Fantasy fans as Square Enix has
delayed Final Fantasy 15 for two whole
months Final Fantasy 15 will be released
globally on November 29th but that's two
whole months later than the previously
scheduled September 30th launch date the
new date will allow the development
teams time to further polish and conduct
quality testing so that the reality of
the game can match the expectations of
both the fans and the creative teams
game director Hajime Tabata made a video
and said from the moment we joined this
project our vision was to create a level
of freedom and realism previously unseen
in the series regrettably we need a
little bit more time to deliver on this
vision and are confident that this new
release date will help us achieve this
to ease the tension they released a
whole hour of additional gameplay
footage and it's looking pretty good you
can even go fishing if you were worried
about the movie King's glib don't be the
movie has not changed from its original
release date Kings glaive will come to
theaters on August nineteenth digital HD
on August 30th and DVD on October fourth
we also reviewed that so you gotta go to
gamespot to check
most of the time people want to be part
of the one percent but not when it comes
to no man's sky because that's the
percentage of people having issues with
the game luckily no man's sky released a
patch this week while the full patch
notes have not been released director
Sean Murray wrote on Twitter that the
update adds support for more hardware
and improves frame rate for lower spec
computers the developer also wrote on
Twitter that less than 1% of players
have reported issues though this is
presumably only counting people who have
filed official support tickets whatever
the case Murray said we're going to
resolve roughly seventy percent of them
this week with the patch although the
patch is released and we've downloaded
it there's no patch notes so we're not
entirely sure what's in there but Sean
Murray said hello games is totally
focused on customer support efforts
right now after these initial issues are
resolved the studio will move on to
improving and adding features into the
game features likes and planets and
giant worms and things that I thought
were already in the game next up we have
new information and new images of the
ps4 four-point-oh update sony's john
kohler outlined some of the new features
for the update which is codenamed
Shingen people in the public beta
program selected for the beta should now
be on the lookout for an email with
details on how to get started but let's
go over all those juicy details first
the ps4's main user interface is
changing to become more refined and
easier to use the overall look will
remain the same but a lot of adjustments
and improvements have been made ps4
four-point-oh makes changes to the Quick
Menu to make it faster and easier to use
with the update applied the menu will
only cover a portion of the screen so
you don't have to completely leave
gameplay to access it Kohler States
we've added several new items to the
Quick Menu letting you quickly get info
without having to back to the home
screen you can see the online status of
your friends shortcuts to quickly access
your party favorite groups communities
and more you can also customize the
quick menu removing or adding items as
you see fit the ps4's share menu has
also been updated like the Quick Menu it
only covers a portion of the screen it
will save the last social network you
shared video clips for screenshots to
making the process of sharing a
screenshot or video faster and more
streamlined and while we're talking
about sharing things from your ps4
Twitter videos uploaded can now be
hundred and forty seconds long they used
to be only ten how am I supposed to
convey how dumb this creature in no
man's sky looks in 10 seconds it's
ridiculous look at him dumb as hell ps4
four-point-oh also adds much requested
folders in an effort to help users
organize their content better in our top
news story of the week is something we
all totally expected there's a
class-action lawsuit against Pokemon go
for some players being really loud
creepy people irritated by how Pokemon
go draws people to a park near their
home a metro detroit couple has filed a
class-action lawsuit against the
creators of the massively popular mobile
game the Detroit Free Press reports that
a couple sued developer niantic Nintendo
as well as partners of the pokemon
company in California federal court
they're suing to try and stop niantic
from putting Pokemon on or near private
properties unless they have the owners
blessing the couple explained in the
lawsuit that they're fed up with Pokemon
go players walking on their lawn looking
in their windows and even swearing at
them in some cases you see this couple
lives across the street from Wahby Park
which is a Pokemon go gym while seven
pocus tops are in the nearby area so
hundreds of people are coming by on any
given day now that does sound annoying
and I think most people would get
frustrated but here's where it gets a
little money grabby additionally the
lawsuit asks that a share of Pokemon
goes revenue should be given to
residents whose properties are claimed
to have fuel the game's wild popularity
I can promise you this in no way is a
property in Detroit fueling the game's
popularity niantic allows anyone to
request an exclusion using this form but
there's no guarantee they'll actually
remove it this lawsuit doesn't really
surprise me and I would expect more in
the future we'll keep you up to date
with the latest people to lawyer up on
Pokemon go so check back to gamespot for
more info
and those are our top five news stories
of the week it's time for me to hit the
dusty trail but I should see you guys
again on Monday so have a good weekend